I mean are we really going to let Warner
Brothers screw this up forever
so because I can't seem to stop talking
about it let's talk about DC and Warner
Brothers attempts to make DC into movies
one more time specifically there's
something that I kind of want to address
which is that in response to especially
my very ranty video that I did really
ripping into the DC EU and Warner
Brothers specifically a lot of people
had well not a lot but a number of
people had expressed a desire to see um
the DC properties bought by Disney I
presume so that it could be handled the
same way that Disney handles the Marvel
properties now you'd be forgiven for
thinking that that's something that I'd
be in favor of given that the DC related
video I made before that really ran t 1
I said that I kind of wished Warner
Brothers would sell DC and at the time I
said I I'm not going to say it was
completely joking but that was just a
general wish enough of may I have put a
lot of specific thought into it this way
I really want to make it very clear
Disney should never own DC Comics of
those DC characters that would be
horrible that would be the worst thing
that could happen yes even worse than
what Warner Brothers is doing with these
characters now let me be clear on
something I'm not saying Disney would
handle it as bad as Warner Brothers is I
do think Warner Brothers is completely
screwing this up but there's a lot of I
mean I'm not sure how much thought
people have thought into when they rise
Oh
Disney should just buy no number of
reasons first of all clearly write them
one basket look I
I like Disney alive I like how they
handle the various entertainment arms in
that they basically assign a head to a
certain sort of division of stuff and
let them do that job Kathleen Kennedy
runs Lucasfilm John Lasseter is running
Disney Animation Kevin Feige runs Marvel
and they let those people do that job
they don't micromanage them which a lot
of indications is what Warner Brothers
tends to do if the
executives the warner brothers can't
stop themselves from really getting
their fingers into everything so i do
like the way that disney handles that
sort of end of things that i like their
approach in general but disney is not
flawless there are things I have issues
with Disney with I absolutely hate these
live-action remake of their animated
films I'm not going to go through that
Rand again but I've done a video on it
before if you want to check out my
issues with that so I don't think Disney
is above criticism or anything like that
but I do like how they handle stuff and
I do think Warner Brothers is making a
mess of it
but it's a really bad idea to have
everything you handled by one company
because even though what Disney is doing
now is good it makes a lot of sense and
I think is yielding a lot of positive
results any company can go south at any
point ownership changes hands people
retire approaches change I mean did
Disney itself has been badly run in the
past Disney in the late 70s the early
80s was not in good shape Little Mermaid
kicked off that initial Disney
Renaissance but even by the late 90s
testing was in bad shape again they
would crank out these awful directed
video sequels to think so any company
especially any company handling and
entertainment thing can go south and to
put all your eggs in one basket like
that to have everything owned by Disney
that's a horrible idea because then if
the company ever just goes south that
means that everything super you're
related go south no that's the first
thing now the other thing the other
reason why Disney absolutely should
never own DC is that Disney is more
homogenized it can't be the only flavor
out there you need something out there
that is distinctively deliberately
different that is handl different with a
different flavor and again this might be
confusing people will like worldwide
relies in TV movies they look and feel
different get but they're bad they're
poorly constructed with badly motivated
and badly explained characters and the
editing especially someone like Suicide
Squad was atrocious so I mean those are
just bad movies but if one company owned
everything
the competition's gone the attempt to
outdo or to think differently is gone
now I appreciate that Warner Brothers
has been trying to come out things
differently than how Disney and it
hasn't worked but I do appreciate that
they are trying to do something
differently and I even to a certain
extent even though they don't agree with
it understand why people latch on to the
fact that Warner Brothers is doing it is
doing it differently from Disney and
really kind of championing that in their
defense of these movies and honestly
that's fine again I don't care for the
result but not everything should be done
in the same way not everything should be
handled by the same company would I
still kind of like one of others to sell
off DC yeah kind of but I mean who the
heck would buy it because Warner
Brothers they're not going to sell off
just the movie right and keep the rest
of them you need to remember Warner
Brothers Time Warner omens DC lock stock
and barrel that's the comic book sets
the TV shows that the movies that's the
toys that's the works they wouldn't
option just the movies unless they were
in extreme dire financial straits which
was how Marvel ended up licensing out
various movie properties you know back
before well before it built his own
studio to make his own movies that
helped Fox ended up with x-men and
Fantastic Four that's how Sony end up
with spider-man but they did that
because they were dire financial straits
so unless Warner Brothers is in that
situation they're never going to sell
off just the movie rights by themselves
and they're not going to sell the entire
thing because it's too expanded it's too
lucrative why would you sell up a
multi-platform multimedia franchise like
that and more to the point who could
afford it really only Disney could
afford it what are the other games out
there Sony's Tony can't afford it
especially with the way their film
division has been lately paramount can't
afford it Universal can't afford it Fox
can't afford it well maybe but that'd be
a stretch for a partially below foot I
don't think anybody could put in an
offer that would be worth that would be
worth it except Disney and as I said
Disney should not own the entire pie you
know I don't know if I have an overall
point that I'm building too with this I
just kind of wanted to say this because
I saw enough people comment on
my videos saying yeah Disney should buy
DC and I even responded to some of those
comments and I just I don't think that
at all and I kind of want to just throw
it out there like look for all my
criticism of Warner Brothers and I will
continue to criticize the Warner
Brothers until they put out a good
product I don't think that Disney should
own the world I don't think that's good
for anybody I don't think it's good for
the fans I don't think it's good for the
properties I don't think it's good for
Disney Disney needs other people you
know vying for that same pie you need
competition in these creative fields
otherwise they get complacent then they
could just give us anything and I don't
even want Warner Brothers to stop making
a DC movie I want them to stop the
approach that they've been doing I kind
of want them to stop making them in this
universe but I don't want them to stop
trying I want them to keep trying big
and unfortunately that does mean at
least so far that they've been failing
big but dizzy put your checkbook away
don't ever buy the DC properties and
Warner Brothers keep them but let's just
get a grip that's it just kind of wanted
to get it off my chest that's all I've
got on this one folks
what are your thoughts on the idea of
Disney owning DC do you think it would
be a good thing do you think it would be
a bad thing do you want me to stop
talking about DC whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter and
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]